ils ont toujours formé une équipe jean
chrétien répétait que sans sa femme il
ne serait pas devenu premier ministre le
ministre des affaires étrangères peut
témoigner de la force tranquille qu'elle
une chrétiens représentaient pour son
mari c'était une femme d'abord qui était
aux côtés de son mari pas derrière son
mari qui était toujours là moi je me
rappelle d'innombrables discussions au
lac des piles justement et on faisait
toujours ça à 3 aline chrétien avait 15
ans lorsqu'elle a rencontré jean
chrétien
elle venait d'une famille modeste
autodidacte elle est devenue polyglotte
mais surtout la principale conseillère
de son mari qu'elle femme qu'elle
conseillère et durant cette très longue
carrière politique que de sacrifices
je pense que n'importe qui n'a pas lu
tout cas tout c'était quelqu'un qui
avait toujours dans mon jeu c'était
aline chrétien même protéger son mari
lorsqu un intrus armé est entré au 24
sussex au beau milieu d'une nuit de
novembre 1995 elle a verrouillé la porte
de leur chambre avant de réveiller jean
chrétien dans une déclaration écrite le
premier ministre justin trudeau affirme
que le pays lui doit beaucoup
hélas fidèlement servi les québécois et
tous les canadiens dit il défendu le
multiculturalisme et le bilinguisme et
contribuer à nous rapprocher les uns des
autres
jean chrétien père sa coéquipière son
rock sont alliés avec qui il aura été
mariée pendant 63 ans